hello I'm Eleanor - and welcome to my
office this video is going to be about
demonstrating and introducing you to the
GigaPan
epic and epic 100 and the type of
digital cameras that we find work really
well with that equipment to take great
panoramas and what I have in front of me
is an epic 100 it's very similar to the
epic except that it's bigger
dimensionally so it's wider and taller
and it has a slot that moves and I'll be
showing you that so that it can
accommodate larger cameras but for the
most part the menus are similar and I'm
going to stick with this for simplicity
to introduce you to the system let's
start by talking about the hardware
itself we call this the robot and then
you've got the digital camera and all
together you have the GigaPan system the
reason we call this a robot is it has
moving parts and let me just go through
those a little bit with you and explain
it to you first of all what is important
about the panorama process is you want
to be able to take your camera and point
it in multiple orientations take
pictures one at a time and then later
take all those overlapping pictures and
put them together into one giant very
high-resolution image that's explorable
so this robot needs to be able to hold
your camera and move it around on the
bottom we have a stepper motor this is
called the pan motor you'll notice
actually that on the bottom of this
robot there is a nonstick non-skid
coating that non-skid coating is nice
because it means you can actually rest
this on top of an object like a table or
railing in a museum and get pretty good
shots even without a tripod so that's
the pan motor and you can see that when
the robots off I can move it by hand we
have a tilt motor for the pitch of the
camera and that's right here it's the
same exact thing and it also has a sort
of non-slip surface on it and I can move
that by hand it's not so easy on the
epic 100 you should be gentle with this
on the epic it has a lower gear ratio
and it's easier to move by hand because
it's not designed for as heavy a camera
and the last motor we've got is a servo
here a servo motor and that has a
robotic finger attached to it that's why
this is a robot so we can push down on
the shutter to take pictures and that's
of course what makes this such a funny
robot since the only universal way we
have of talking to inexpensive cameras
is the shutter button it makes a lot of
sense to be able to put
that down directly ourselves so a few
more things about the robot first of all
there is a level bubble here that's very
useful when you put this on a tripod to
arrange and make sure that you're as
level as possible so that your panorama
comes out more or less straight that's
important another important point is a
connection the servo moves and because
it moves we have to have this flexible
cable here connecting it to the robot if
you're to unplug this it's a cable that
is just a three pin connector and the
trick with that is there's an epic
question which is it's not necessarily
obvious which way to plug it in now the
good news is if you plug it in wrong
when you turn the robot on it says
you've plugged in the cable wrong so
then you can try it the other way the
reason this is removable is because on
the epic 100 it's actually useful to be
able to remove this and then plug in
instead a remote trigger and if you're
using a camera like the g11 that we'll
be talking about in a bit you can
actually unplug this remove this unit
altogether by unscrewing here and you
can put the g11 on here you can get the
cable from us that allows you to connect
directly to the g11 from here and then
your robot will electronically tell the
g11 to actually take the pictures and so
that works for the higher-end
point-and-shoot cameras that actually
have remote trigger remote triggers now
the other interesting thing to know
about the system is of course the
batteries so let's talk about that the
batteries are in a compartment and those
of you who have used the old beta units
see that this is quite different from
that here we have a pretty easy way of
taking the batteries in and out there
just double-a batteries the six of them
a few words about batteries in general I
don't recommend that you use alkaline
because they don't last very long you're
only going to get a three or four
Panorama is out of alkaline in my
opinion these are really nice
high-energy nickel metal hydride
batteries these are 2600 milliamp hours
each and that's a pretty good battery to
use so you want to go for batteries that
have a lot of amp hours on board and you
want to use nickel metal hydride and
have a nickel metal hydride battery
charger that's the way to go with
batteries like these I can easily take
ten really large GigaPan panoramas in
the field before I need to change
batteries and when we get to the robot
you'll see it actually tells you how
many volts you have running so you have
an idea when you're running low on
battery power you know what I do is I
actually leave the batteries in my
backpack inside of this case but
separate from the robot when I go hiking
so that there's no chance that the
buttons are going to get hit as I hike
around and turn the thing on and often
I'll get to the panoramic place and then
I'll actually put the batteries in for
the shot so that's one nice way to
protect yourself so we'll put the
batteries in and we've talked about the
lower mechanism of the system it's time
to talk about one of the most important
things of all which is actually placing
the camera on the robot so I have three
different cameras here that I want to
just talk about briefly and then we'll
use one of the cameras to really go
through all the menus with you these
three cameras happen to be cannons of
course you can use any make of camera on
the GigaPan and the let's start with the
smallest one actually this tiny camera
that I have here is called a it's in the
SD series from Canon this is the SD 780
is elf it's 12 megapixels and it has I
think it three times optical zoom the
reason this is a great choice is it's
one of the smaller cameras from Canon
that doesn't have too much been getting
so it's reasonable that way it has some
zoom it has pretty high quality optics
and you're able to do some of the most
important things with this camera even
though it's a small point-and-shoot
camera which is in this case you can put
it in what's called program mode on this
camera and then you can fix the exposure
and the focus and especially fixing the
exposure turns out to be really
important in GigaPan because you want
all the pictures that you take to have
similar enough exposure that when you
stitch them all together into one
picture the same sky doesn't look like
it's different colors and different
brightnesses because that gets really
well it gets ugly
so this is a small camera this is in
fact the camera that we use
educationally now at the other end if
you have an epic 100 it's a rather large
unit and it has this particular trick
the plates on which the camera sits
actually comes out and the dimensions of
this area are quite large
and so you can put really large
point-and-shoot cameras that are
essentially nearly DSLRs on this this is
a nice example this is a Powershot SX 10
is it's sort of the successor to the old
SX 100 series and what's great about
these cameras is they have a fantastic
zoom this has a twenty times optical
zoom in fact twenty times optical zoom
is so good that you'll often want to
decide during your GigaPan shooting do I
really want to use full zoom or is this
180 degree picture something where I
only really need about half of my zoom
so whereas on the small elf you're
always going to full zoom it becomes
natural and automatic to do that on the
camera like this you're really going to
make decisions about zoom because this
is a Canon camera and it's pretty
high-end the menus on it are nearly
identical to the Powershot g11 and so
I'm going to use the g11 and I'll talk
about why and that menus that you see on
there transfer extremely well to this
and actually also to the small PowerShot
ELPH the SD 780 that we talked about so
that's the really large camera and
indeed it fits on the epic 100 now the
camera that were going to be talking
about right now is the g11 this is one
of my favorite cameras from Canon and I
like it because it's very compact this
is the best camera that we can recommend
for the epic so the epic 100 will fit
this nearly DSLR version of the FX 10 is
but the epic doesn't have this
retractable plate and it's actually a
little bit smaller on the inside which
is great for hiking but it does fit the
Canon G 11 which is an outstanding
camera and I think it reminds me of some
of the old SLR s I used to use because
it has these dials on top so this is the
camera we're going to use today and I'm
going to use this camera to show you how
you go about mounting your camera on
your robot so firstly like these side
units because we don't need them to be
extended for this camera now in putting
the camera on the robot the first thing
to do is to realize that often there's
some things you need access to before
you lock your camera down in particular
in the case of the g11 the SD card is
down here and the battery is down here I
almost always use at least a four
gigabyte SD card usually a 16 gigabyte
SD card I highly recommend you use
something nice and large
because you want to be able to take four
or five hundred pictures that the
maximum resolution offered without even
worrying about running out of memory and
of course in this case the batteries
down here and so between the battery of
the camera and the batteries and the
panorama I can take something like ten
panoramas and then it's time to change
both batteries out all right let's go
ahead and look at how to mount this on
on the robot there first thing we do is
notice that there's a quarter inch screw
on the epoch 100 it's the same on the
epoch and it just slides left and right
in the slot that sliding is important
because it lets us adjust the left/right
position of the camera we're going to
take the regular quarter inch hole that
you might use to mount your camera to a
tripod and instead of mounting to a
tripod well mount directly to here I
like to get the robot arm out of the way
and then I'll turn this so I have some
room and I can see what I'm doing and
off we go you'll notice that the screw
is captive so it won't fall out of the
robot way it's not connected to a camera
which is nice I screw that in part ways
and this is on a rubberized mount so
it's pretty safe what's slide very
easily once I've screwed it in part way
I'm going to sight the lens to this
diamond and this diamond and this notch
are important because they represent the
center of rotation of the robot so we
want the center of the lens to
correspond to that and so now by having
the slot be loose I can move left and
right like that
and I'll stop when the center of
rotation is roughly right which is about
there and then I'll tighten it down so
that's one adjustment that we make every
time we load the camera onto the robot
now let's talk about centering the
camera in general as I take pictures
here I've got you know this GigaPan epic
Pro in front of me and then I've got my
book pay book case further behind and
there's a problem as this pans and tilts
like that
if the foreground moves relative to the
background that means if there's
parallax then the pictures aren't going
to stitch together because if I line up
the pro the book case will be out of
alignment if I line up the book case the
pro will be out of alignment so it's
really important to do your best to
cause the camera as it's moving by the
robot not to induce any parallax now
there's something called NPP no power
Bax point or the nodal point the idea is
we want the optical center of the camera
to be what the robot rotates about so
that nothing moves the environment kind
of like what your eyeball does when you
look around
so we've already adjusted for the center
of the optics in the left-right
direction using that diamond now we need
to adjust up down and forward and
backward we do both up down and forward
and backward using a single adjustment
system and that's right here on the side
arm so I'm going to unscrew it and show
you how that works there is a slot on
this arm that slides forward and
backward and that lets us make a for apt
adjustment at the same time this screw
isn't in the middle of this disc and so
by rotating the disc you'll notice that
the screw moves up and down so I can
make a vertical adjustment that way and
I can move the center of where I'm
pivoting my for EFT adjustment in the
vertical direction what I want is
vertically I want the lenses Center and
the center of this disc to be the same
which in this case means roughly right
there right about straight with the g11
now that's great because in the vertical
sense that means as I move about I'm not
going to be inducing parallax now let's
talk about the hard one forward and
backward
now I'll give you the bad news first
when we go ahead and tighten this right
around here for now the bad news is on a
camera system that has zoom the fore/aft
nodal point moves depending on how sumed
in you are and that's a surprise to some
people so in particular when i zoom in
all the way like this what happens is I
zoom forward and zoom into the picture
the nodal point moves back and in fact
it's very close to the back of the
camera whereas if i zoom out pull back
and get a wide-angle view the nodal
point moves forward so you will have to
experiment with your camera and try and
find a position for the zoom that you
typically use now with the g11
I always zoom it in all the way and I
happen to know that when I'm using then
all the way in the situation like this I
want the camera pretty far
forward way forward like that so that's
what I would do on the g11 so the
interesting news is you can actually use
your eyes to estimate where the nodal
point is for aft so when I look in that
lens and zoom in I can actually see what
looks like the back of the lens to me
your eyes do a really good job of
estimating where the back is and when
you zoom out you'll actually see what
looks like the back of the lens move
forward so that's pretty cool it's a
nice way of telling what's going on
that's one point the second point is you
can do research on the Internet and we
have a website even on which we talk
about where the nodal point is for
various cameras so there's ways for you
to get more information
third you can actually experiment so you
can take your camera put it on a GigaPan
and you can set up a scene where you
have something close in something far
away and you can literally move the
robot back and forth taking care that
you're rotating on the base and you can
see if the handle is moving or not and
you can adjust this until it's clear to
you that the object that's close isn't
moving relative to the background as you
just spin this left and right like that
and that works perfectly well to last
but certainly not least if you're taking
a picture of the Grand Canyon this
doesn't matter that is to say if
everything is pretty far away
there is no parallax issue if you close
one eye and move your head around
nothing moves relative to anything else
this is a problem in situation where you
have a scene where you have quite close
objects and four objects in the same
scene so for instance a flower bed in
your backyard or an arboretum or such
also this doesn't matter if you have
relatively flat world so if you're in an
art museum you're taking pictures of
some beautiful paintings and wall text
on the wall everything is roughly the
same distance away it just doesn't
matter nearly as much so you also should
think about the context and think about
whether you need to worry about this or
not that's all we need to discuss for
those adjustments the next one is the
robot arm so the finger has two
adjustments one is height in that
direction and the other allows you to do
two directions dimensions of adjustment
and that's this now for height what I
like to do is I like to push up on the
finger and then give myself enough
height to get in here and adjust the
zoom I want to be able to comfortably
adjust the zoom
and it's perfectly fine to have two or
three centimeters of space here that's
all right so now I'll go ahead and bear
down on that screw now to actually
adjust so that I'm hitting the actual
trigger button head-on what I like to do
is Center it push down on the trigger be
sure that I'm in the right place and
then tighten this down one of the places
that you'll commonly find people have
made mistakes with the GigaPan is
they'll adjust the robot trigger finger
carelessly it'll be right on the edge of
the button it'll work for the first 40
pictures and then maybe it'll stop
working for five pictures and that's a
shame because they go home they have
this beautiful 45 picture panorama and
the last five pictures never got taken
there's two way to do with that first of
all of course pay attention to the
trigger button make sure you've
tightened this down well second of all
and just as important pay attention to
the GigaPan while you're taking your
panorama make sure you're looking and
are assured that in fact the pictures
are getting taken just when you expect
them to be taken so I want to start by
talking about setting up the camera and
some of the things I'm going to talk
about are setup issues that you need to
do once you'll have the menu set up
correctly for Jigga panning other issues
I'm going to talk about are things like
exposure lock that you're going to have
to do every time you're taking a
panorama all over again for that
situation for that specific context so
let's go through background setup first
and talk about the modes that these
cameras have and what really matters to
make a good panorama so now we're going
to talk about the menu and these are the
settings that you're going to make
essentially once and then this will be
appropriate for all panoramas now I've
hit the menu button to get to this mode
you just hit the menu button to get in
and out of it and so we'll go back into
menu and I'm going to walk you down the
menu items that are most important for
giga panning first of all digital zoom
let's talk about digital zoom you want
it off the reason is you want each
picture you take to be as
high-resolution as high fidelity as
possible and the digital zoom is simply
amplifying the picture without using
optics so you want maximum optics
optical zoom but no digital zoom the
next one that matters in terms of
autofocus it doesn't matter so much
because you're often going to be taking
gig depends with
out-of-focus and there are situations in
which you will use autofocus in a
situation where you're in that art
museum and everything is flat it makes a
lot of sense to nail the focus and lock
it and I'll show you how to do that on
this camera and other cameras have
similar ways to do it in a situation
where you are in that Arboretum and
things are close and far away
autofocus can be good because it's kind
of like focus stacking you're taking a
picture of the close objects close
focused on it and you're taking a
picture of the far object far focused on
it and that can be very useful and we'll
talk about that a little bit more when
we talk about pausing and retaking
because there's nice ways to trick the
camera into giving you just the right
focus on each picture the next one that
matters a whole lot is review I've got
review set to two seconds and that is
good because longer than two seconds
gets in the way of picking to give your
pan and attending to what's going on two
seconds gives you enough time so that as
the robot is taking pictures you can see
on the screen what happened did that van
that was driving by get in the picture
and ruin it should I pause and go back
and retake that from the robot or my
find are the pictures getting taken at
all or is my finger missing or is the
memory card full review information I
sometimes have it off and sometimes have
it on detailed both are acceptable
detailed is nice because you get the
histogram and the histogram allows you
to make sure that you don't have pixels
that are saturated off the right end or
completely black off the left end as
long as your pixels is somewhere in the
middle you can imagine post-processing
with image editing tools and making sure
that you can adjust things like the
brightness but if you've got pixels all
the way at the right end or all the way
the left and the problem is there's no
information and so it's very difficult
to adjust those and make them better so
review mode is really important I leave
it on two seconds typically let's talk
about image stabilization is mode or
some cameras call it anti vibration
image stabilization is a funny Beast the
problem is the GigaPan acts neither like
a tripod nor like a human holding the
camera it moves quickly and stops and
takes a picture and so image
stabilization is computer gets all
confused am I on a tripod no I'm moving
well now I'm really steady I must be on
a tripod and as it switches back and
forth between
those two guesses it moves the image and
you can end up with blur so we tend to
recommend leave image stabilization off
now if you're in a windy situation if
you're in a situation with vibration of
course you should experiment and there's
lots of reasons why that's a good place
to go and experiment and see if image
stabilization happens to help you or not
let's now go to the next menu which is
the Tools menu and I'm going to go down
to an important part of this which is
the power saving side so I'm going to
click in on power saving auto power down
because it takes time to set up the
GigaPan robot and camera and decide what
your frame is going to be it's really
frustrating to be doing that whole thing
and then have the camera turn itself off
in the middle so we recommend turning
off Auto power-down by the same token
display off is something you want to not
have happen for as long as possible go
for the maximum keep that camera on and
operating properly warning in some of
these cameras including this one if the
display turns itself off you will often
lose things like auto exposure lock an
auto focus lock I'm actually correction
the g11 doesn't do that but I'm quite
sure that the SD 780 does that so you
really want to make that number large if
possible that's power saving and that's
the other really important aspect that I
wanted you to see that's it so now we
can go out of the menu and let me talk a
little bit about how I typically set up
my whole system for Giggy panning on an
epic or and I pick 100 base so what I'll
do is set up my tripod of course and
this is heavy so you're going to put it
on a nice sturdy tripod not not a 18
dollar tripod but something a little
more expensive than that and you set
your system up or you put it on a
tabletop before I turn the GigaPan
epic or epic 100 on because I can move
this by hand relatively easily I'll
actually go through and set up the
camera and I want to go through that
process with you for a really unusual
GigaPan we're going to take a GigaPan of
some historical GigaPan units that are
behind me on the shelf so what I do at
this point is I'll set up the shot first
by zooming in all the way making sure I
understand the level of resolution I'm
going to be at and then I'll go in and
actually start
to adjust the things that matter in a
day-to-day sense now I've put the
display mode in such a setting that I
actually see everything and an important
point to make to you is if we look at
the top of the camera it's an M or
manual mode that's very important we
need as much consistency between the
shots as possible so you have the same
exposure we want certainly the same
white balance otherwise we will get
different color temperatures and as we
knit knit these together it'll look very
odd so I typically put that in manual
mode I'll typically put the ISO on the
finest level of detail possible these
small pointin shirts have relatively
small image sensors and so a low ISO is
particularly meaningful as we talked
about Pro units you can of course use
much higher ISO values and that's just
fine but on these cameras and the
signal-to-noise ratios they have you
really want to go for 80 or 100 if you
can I'm going to leave it on 100 right
now when I'm outside I always use 80
without fail
so when manual mode we've got ISO of 100
that's two of the settings that you're
making now let's go and look at the
settings on-screen I'm going to go ahead
and hit the middle of the little donut
here called function set and walk down
we don't want auto white balance you can
see auto white balance showing here
instead of auto white balance what we
want to do is pick a specific white
balance that we're going to use across
the entire panorama in this case it's a
cloudy day there's also some fluorescent
lighting in here so let me see which
looks better
that's way too blue so we'll go with
cloudy day there we go so we've chosen
our white balance setting now let's go
down the rest of this menu this has a
neutral density filter which is
essentially like sunglasses for the
camera we don't want that because I want
to get in as much light as possible
what does matter here I want to take
single shots every time I have the robot
press the button I want a single picture
to get taken that's fine and I want
large in other words I want the highest
resolution superfine setting possible
and typically with any camera you're
using you're going to go for the largest
and most superfine version of resolution
that's available on the camera that's
really important in general we recommend
you go ahead and use JPEG mode so if
your camera supports raw and
a peg go ahead and use JPEG unless you
need to make significant post-processing
modifications to the images before you
upload them to the stitcher in which
case you could go to raw do all sorts of
work because you've contained as much
information as possible and then save as
JPEG and send to the stitcher the
stitcher also supports 16-bit Tiff's so
you can do eight 16-bit TIFF you can do
8-bit JPEG okay so that's the image size
that's it for the left side of the
display now on the right side of the
display it's important to note the flash
is off you don't want your flash on for
obvious reasons we're taking hundreds of
pictures we'll use up the battery
we're in manual mode which is exactly
what we want because that allows us to
adjust the shutter speed and the iris
now let's talk a little bit about the
iris and about the shutter speed on this
camera when you're zoomed in all the way
F 4.5 is as small as it gets as the
f-stop gets and that means that the
aperture can only be so wide not very
wide in fact and in this situation
that's pretty dark I'd be going for as
big as it gets and then I'd be adjusting
the shutter but let's talk about iris a
little bit there are some interesting
problems you get into with all of these
digital cameras as you make the iris
really small that means when you make
the f-stop really large you get into a
diffraction problem and with Giga pans
you really care about the how
crystal-clear that image is as your iris
gets really small and you get
diffraction it gets softer it gets
blurrier actually so this is something
you should experiment with on the g11
for example I try very hard to never go
beyond about F 5.6 because you really
start having significant diffraction
problems and I stay as big as I can but
there's a trade-off right because if
your iris is large then you have very
shallow depth of field so especially if
things are close like this and you're
zoomed in all the way it's very
difficult to get everything in focus at
the same time so my preference if
nothing is moving is keep that iris
large make the shutter speed nice and
long if I have to now let's talk about
what happens at night because sometimes
you're going to want to do that and it's
nighttime and you want a big iris and no
matter what you do you have a 2 or 3
second exposure so how do you do that
well you'll do the 2 or 3 second
exposure but in the situation like that
I'll do something else
actually introduced a two second timer
now this is nice because if you have a
two second timer then you can have a
nice long exposure and when you press
the button on the camera it waits two
seconds and then takes a picture by the
time it takes a picture there's no
vibration there's nothing moving and so
that two second timer gives you the
chance of everything being still and in
night time photography or museum
photography I find that two-second
exposure is specially useful now I'm
going to go ahead and turn off the
two-second exposure so that it takes
pictures instantly for now and so now
what we've got is one twentieth of a
second at four point five in this
relatively dark situation now once
you've identified all those settings
there's one other setting you have to be
aware of which is the focus we talked
about this a little bit before if you're
in a scene where everything's at the
same distance go to manual focus nail
the focus and be done for infinity if
you're in the Grand Canyon situation in
a situation where things are truly at
different focuses you can try leaving
autofocus on and see how it does
although you may find that when you get
to things like the clouds in the sky it
does poorly you could pause it during
the GigaPan during the panorama
acquisition you can pause it go back and
change the focus setting so you can be
manual it go to infinity at that point
or you can be an autofocus and switch to
manual and go to infinity and then you
can resume taking the panorama on the
blue sky that way so that's an idea for
dealing with the fact that some places
should be auto focus and some places you
want to lock the focus because they
don't have enough contrast enough detail
for focusing to work well that describes
everything we need to know about taking
the pictures with the camera one of the
important next steps is actually trying
it out so I'll take a picture then once
I've taken the picture I'll go and look
at it so I'm going to go to the mode
where you're looking at the pictures
I'll zoom in look at it in gory detail
and wow I've got a nice picture I'm able
to see the little buttons on the
old-fashioned GigaPan unit quite well
I'm seeing little chinks in the aluminum
so I'll zoom out so now I know that the
pictures that camera takes are are
reasonable in this case it's autofocus
and the autofocus is doing a good job at
that distance which is not surprising
great so I'm happy with the quality of
the picture and I've set up my camera
that covers everything that I go through
with the camera to make sure it's
prepared and ready for the panorama
acquisition in this case of my bookshelf
now we turn our attention to the robot
so now let's look at the menus that the
epic 100 has which are largely similar
to the ones that the epic has when you
turn it on you have the new panorama
menu and I'm going to grab the pen you
already know what new panorama does it
allows you to set the top left bottom
right corners and take your panoramas
the next menu to show you is 360
panorama that's a nice selection where
you know you want to get pictures all
the way around when you choose this menu
it simply has you choose the top edge
and the bottom edge of the panorama
using the top and bottom keys and then
it takes all the pictures around we're
going to the next menu last panorama
last panorama is really interesting and
there's some nice special effects you
can do with it last panorama takes the
boundaries of the previous panorama you
just took go to the top left corner and
lets you take it again you can actually
use the right left up down keys to move
the robot to any cell in the panorama
and then start there and start taking
pictures so you can be surgical you can
take a panorama let's say of the bush in
South Africa on a safari then you can
wait for a giraffe to show up you can
click last panorama and then use these
to manually move the camera until you
have the giraffe in the centre of a
frame and your snaps to the grid so
you're in the panorama grid and then you
can press the button by hand or with the
rollout trigger and get that giraffe and
then on the stitcher side you can drop
that picture in by replacing the picture
of that part of the bush with the
picture with the giraffe in it not going
to picture with the giraffe so last
panel is really quite effective for fast
forwarding going to a particular place
and surgically modifying pictures for
yourself options we're going to go ahead
and enter that and look at some very
important options first one time per
picture this is a big deal the robot
doesn't know directly when the camera is
done taking a picture and so the robot
needs to be told by you how many seconds
to wait between pictures now my default
when I'm outside is 3 seconds 3 seconds
is enough time that I can take a hundred
picture panoramas and it doesn't take
forever
it's only a couple of three minutes and
three seconds is usually enough time
we're outside if the exposure is really
fast on the camera you're going to be
alright you're going to have enough time
for the camera to do its thing however
that's not the case for indoor
photography and especially for dark
photography let's say you're in a
situation in a museum or a dark night
night scene where in fact the camera is
spending let's say one-and-a-half
seconds exposure well if you set that
thing to one-and-a-half seconds exposure
especially on some of these cameras once
you get above one or two seconds
exposure they'll do a 1 second or 2
second exposure then they'll close the
shutter for 2 seconds do another
exposure to get a measurement of the
black noise and they'll compare those to
create the best picture they can so
suddenly your two-second exposure is
taking four seconds and then it has to
write the picture to the SD card so you
take four seconds plus something so now
the shutter delay needs to go from three
seconds which gives you just enough time
to move and be ready and finish review
mode and get ready to shoot again all
the way to something like eight or nine
seconds so don't be shy about making
this number large one of the worst
things that can happen to you is you're
in an excellent shot situation you've
set this to some number that's
borderline it's just barely working and
it's working and you get to a picture
that happens to have a lot of detail in
it so the JPEG compression doesn't
compress it as much so it takes a little
longer to write to the SD card than your
other pictures so the camera is not
quite ready and so in this nice picture
that you're capturing most of you end up
going home and realize that in this 200
picture panorama there's these two very
detailed pictures you're just missing
the picture after them because the
picture after them never got taken so
that's the reason to make sure you're
not in a boundary case with that number
below time for picture the next menu is
battery status that's a nice menu it's
indicating that we're at seven point
three volts right now which is a pretty
good value to be at with the batteries
anything above seven volts tells me that
the batteries are in reasonable shape
and we'll go down again start delay
start delay is really useful if you want
to be in the picture or if you are in a
situation where for instance you're
putting your GigaPan unit and camera on
a hot air balloon and setting it up in
the sky not that I've done that myself
but you can imagine doing that so start
delay allows you to go in and say when I
say start the panorama don't start for
15 seconds 30 seconds you can keep going
up to 10 15 minutes so you can
essentially delay the entire panorama
acquisition to whatever you like that's
stuck the lay next multiple shutter this
is a feature that's on Epic 100 but not
on the epic multiple shutter is is
suggesting instead of taking just a
single picture at that location take
multiple pictures and that's fantastic
if you intend to take multiple pictures
and do some kind of high dynamic range
work with that or multifocal planning
work factory reset is doing the obvious
thing expert options expert options are
interesting it's worth taking a quick
look at them buttonholed
is this question of whether you want the
robotic finger to continuously press the
shutter button for the three seconds
that it's pressing it for or depress it
and release it some people feel that
passing continuously induces less
vibration because you're not actually
moving it twice and so there's a debate
there and you can play with it and let
us know what you think checklist allows
you to set whether you want a checklist
to be shown or not just now when I use
the GigaPan there was no checklist but
there's a nice checklist you can turn on
that ask your questions like did you fix
the white balance did you lock the focus
did you lock the exposure and so check
this is very useful for these kinds of
operations shutter method is asking the
question while you're using the robotic
button-pusher or are you using some
other technique for using the shutter
like a remote trigger or a manual point
so remote port if you were to hit okay
says I'm actually using the remote port
to trigger this with a trigger Manuel is
saying the human being is going to press
the button on the camera so don't worry
about pressing the button for me and
that's it picture ordering is another
really interesting menu let me go ahead
and enter that and show you what's going
on right now we're in column mode and
column mode means we start the top left
we take our picture by running down the
column and coming to the right and doing
that again so we're taking the picture a
column at a time instead we could
actually choose to take the picture in
row mode or or
down or row mode up row mode down means
we store the top and we scribe down row
mode up means we start at the bottom and
we scribe up let's talk about why you
would want to use these modes typically
if you're capturing something where the
lights changing rapidly or there's
motion say a sunset it's very important
to you that the adjacent pictures are
taken quickly in rapid succession so row
mode makes a lot of sense
in fact I'll often take sunset shots
with row mode up because as the Sun sets
the grass in front of the Sun is going
to become dark quickly so when I capture
the grass capture the sunset at just the
right time and I can even pause it and
then continue it when I get to the
horizon at just the right moment and
then I want to capture the sky as it's
very colorful as the Sun sets and again
you could pause it if you want for fun
wait for the color of the sky to start
to become quite saturated and then take
the pictures by the same token row mode
is really useful if you're looking at a
really crowded situation like a baseball
game and there's motion because people
don't move up and down they move
sideways so the faster you can take the
pictures sideways the better column mode
turns out to be really nice for
landscapes where nothing is moving just
because I'm used to it and I enjoy that
I'm getting some sky making sure the
exposure is right getting the ground
making sure the ground looks good
so really tests the full range of
exposures and distances for me on that
very first column and then I know
everything is going to be good so that's
the picture ordering situation and
there's a backlight mode and a motor
mode and a firmware version and that's
it so that's the expert options now
we're going to move to the most
important menu of all at the top level
it's called GigaPan setup you've already
noticed that we took that example
panorama and the GigaPan robot had to
move between pictures
well the question is how did it know how
many degrees to move that depends
depending on the camera you use when you
put it at full zoom you may have to move
three degrees you may have to use move
15 degrees between pictures it's tricky
because you want a jacent pictures to
have some overlap say 30% or so
you don't want 70 or 80% overlap because
you're wasting your time and you're
wasting camera and memory space it's
just too much overlap you don't want too
little overlap because the stitcher
needs to have enough pixels in common in
the scene that it can calibrate and
align those pictures just right so it
needs details that match up like that
pine tree in the distance being in both
pictures so that it can make sure it's
it's perfectly aligning everything and
creating one seamless panorama so
GigaPan setup is going to allow us to do
that and I want to just show you how
that works so we're going to hit go
ahead and hit OK and we're going to go
up and down to the camera and show you
what you do current field of view 10.8
degrees now once you do this a few times
you'll know what the right field of view
is for your camera I'm going to go ahead
and hit OK to change it it's going to
say use buttons to align horizon with
the top of the camera screen of course
first you want to set your camera to
whatever zoom you're intending to use
I'm zoomed forward all the way which is
what I want and what I'm going to do is
just pick something in the image in this
case the white cable there and I'm going
to set it by going on the up/down button
until it's on the very top of the screen
then I hit OK and it says reference set
then it says use buttons to align the
horizon or that object with the bottom
of the camera screen so now I'm simply
going to use the up button to move that
cable down now as I move that cable down
in the image it's showing me the current
degrees field of view as measured by the
stepper motors so right now in 4.2
degrees there's five point eight degrees
and so on
I'll move the tip of that cable right to
the bottom of the screen don't worry
about overlap it'll compensate for
overlap for you and I'm at eleven point
five degrees maybe I'll go down a little
bit right there eleven point seven
degrees eleven point five all right we
hit okay so now we've physically
measured the field of view of the camera
in the top up-down direction and the
robot now knows that number that number
is remembered by the robot even when you
turn it off and take the batteries out
so as long as you're using the same
camera fully zoomed in on the same robot
you don't have to worry about that
number of course something that makes a
lot of sense is while you're taking
Gigot pans with the can
look at the pictures that are getting
taken find something in the picture and
when it goes to the next position make
sure what you're seeing is a reasonable
amount of overlap between the pictures
so again you and your eyeballs and brain
checking on the robot and making sure
it's doing the right thing there's no
substitute for that okay that's the set
of GigaPan setups that we need to know
about so we can actually take a picture
I'm going to go ahead and go to the top
level go back to new panoramas and show
you a few more tricks in taking a new
panorama so just to review this we're
going to take a new panorama by making
sure the robot is ready in this case
it's still got the same exposure
settings it had before we're going to
hit okay we're going to set the upper
left and now let's try and be careful of
focus so we're going to go on the top
left of that early GigaPan and it's
going to say set lower right so we go
down to the bottom right corner of the
GigaPan unit the betta unit on the right
I should say the beta unit on the right
so there's a six by three GigaPan and by
the way I'm at the six by three Jeep and
that's 18 pictures but it's 18 pictures
and we don't have a real feel for
whether we're at the very edges of what
it could be at 30 percent overlap I can
go down and right all the way to there
before it goes to 7 by 4 so you can
actually play that game if you wish so
you're capturing the largest space you
can with those 6 by 3 pictures um what
it'll otherwise do is basically squish
them together to get exactly the top
left bottom right corners that you're
asking for so I'm gonna hit OK on that
but now I'm going to play a game to make
sure I get the best focus that I can
just to show you an example the first
thing it says is show panorama yes or
skip I'm going to say skip I don't want
to see the panorama take 18 pictures yes
or cancel I'm going to say yes but now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to pay
careful attention to the robot as it
takes the pictures if the picture looks
focused fine
I've got auto focus on if the picture
doesn't look focused I'm going to pause
it and show you what I do
so taking panorama press X to pause
column one row one off it goes and it
gets a picture in the dark and it's
actually well focused so it goes to the
next position
and gets a good picture and here's a
picture right below my business cards oh
that was really fuzzy so I'll pause this
I paused it but the robots moved on to
the next picture so I'm going to go back
one to go back to the bad picture so
this is the picture that was bad right
so what I'm going to do put my hand out
here make sure that it can focus well by
pushing halfway down and then I'll take
the picture there we go
much better focus and now I'll tell it
to continue I'll go forward one to the
next position because I took that
picture for it and now I'll hit okay go
ahead and continue taking pictures so
don't feel shy about getting in the way
of the robot that way making sure that
is taking a good picture for you
now you could even have gone in and
changed to manual focus mode now go
ahead and stop this because we don't
actually need all these pictures so now
we've covered the settings that the
GigaPan epic has and the epic 100 has in
terms of setting up your image and your
picture in your panorama and making sure
that you're in tune with the robot in
camera and how long the camera is taking
to take pictures and we've go over
you've gone over the camera now let me
just talk about one more advanced issue
which is vignetting and then we're done
so vignette II the problem that you got
is that a lot of these cameras including
the g11
when you zoom them in all the way
especially when you have that wide open
aperture that I said is good which will
happen is the light beam is coming in
through optics that aren't perfect
they're not thousands of dollars worth
of optics and there is an imaging chip
that is pretty small and the boundaries
of the image can be quite dark now this
isn't typically a problem if you're
taking pictures of grass or forests or
trees or people but if you have
something that's really homogeneous and
bright in a color but not saturated not
bright white or black so let's say the
blue sky you got a problem because each
of those pictures that is taking of the
blue sky the middle of it is bright and
the edges are dark so when the stitcher
gets done
the picture is splotchy so what you need
to do is understand what it takes to
make vignetting as small as possible a
problem first of all good can
the better the camera the better the
optics often the better the vignetting
and you can ask that question
second of all you can do post-processing
so you can programmatically go in and
correct the pictures for vignetting and
much more advanced cameras actually have
lenses that are designed to correct with
an getting third thing you can do
keep the aperture a little smaller so
try making the aperture smaller see if
that solves part of your problem so that
you don't have as broad an aperture and
as much of a fringe of the lens being
used and those are the kinds of issues
that you need to think about whenever
you have that beautiful blue sky and you
want to get one beautiful homogeneous
piece of blue sky captured so good luck
with that that's the vignetting problem
that you'll see remember though that
making your apertures small introduces
the other problem which is diffraction
so if you make your aperture really
small to try and get away from
vignetting eventually you're going to
lose some sharpness because of
diffraction so there is a happy medium
and you want to try and forge toward the
medium as much as possible now the SD
780 is a great educational unit because
it's inexpensive and it's tiny easy for
kids to use and I want to show you
briefly how you fix the exposure and and
the focus on this camera because it's
not quite the same everything else in
the menus is exactly the same but the
way you fix the exposures is a little
different and I put it in program mode
I'm going to zoom it in all the way
so in those senses it's very much
similar to the camera you were using
before but here's the trick with fixing
exposure which again is very important
you always want to fix exposure so on
the SD 780 what you need to notice first
of all is there's a little donut here
around the function set button now
function set and the donut exists on the
bigger cameras here is just much much
smaller and harder to see and ordinarily
you use the donut to do things like turn
the flash on and off which of course is
important and turn on the timer and as
you'll recall the timer is great because
you can use it to introduce for instance
a two-second delay so that at night you
can get great GigaPan shots the donut is
also not labeled this way but you can
use it to lock the exposure and the
focus and that's very important so
here's how would you do that we can push
down the shutter and then we can push up
on the top of the donut where there's a
blue rectangle
and it locks the exposure it makes the
adjustment itself so it decided one
fifth of a second F 5.8 but the good
news is it's locked now so all the
pictures will be at that same exposure
so you'd have to hunt to find the right
place to lock the exposure like that for
your overall panorama to lock focus you
push down halfway on the shutter and you
hit the left side of the doughnut where
the mountain and flower are and then a
FL shows up auto focus lock and now all
the pictures will have that focus point
again very useful in certain situations
although I do recommend that you play
with having focus in auto focus mode
some of the time with key given